频繁交易会时
你刚入行
翻推文
看教学视频
走到哪都在讲
不能冲动
不能追单
不能频繁出手
要克制
要等待
要简化
听起来没问题
毕竟市场上失败者众多
而频繁交易者的亏损数据也确实摆在那
但这句话的问题是
他说的太笼统
太绝对太偷懒
他完全忽略了一个事实
没有经历过平繁交易训练的人
根本没有克制的资格
就像一个人从来没做过体能训练
却天天在研究如何避免运动损伤
从没真正跑步过
却总在讲怎么保存体力
你不下场打
根本不知道问题在哪
更不可能建立起一套有效判断
很多人一开始是在频繁交易里
这是真的
但问题不在于你做的多
而在于你做的太随意
做的没有计划
没有记录
没有判断标准
你下单靠情绪
这种靠临场反应
一亏就加码
一涨就追高
亏损权归结为今天行情不好
盈利也没法复盘
每次交易都是一次全新的混乱
每一次错误都当成运气不好
你不是因为做的多才死的
你是因为做的多
做的急
做的乱
每次做错也不记
归因不改
但问题是
如果你不频繁出手
不快速
试错不整理反馈
你又怎么建立自己的交易判断
你连该不该做都没经历过几次错
怎么知道错在哪
交易不是靠听来的
你看过再多京剧
超过最多战法
也不代表你能在实盘中下出一笔合力的单子
因为交易不是只靠知识理解
它更像是一项需要反复训练的技能
和所有技能训练一样
他必须高频出手
反复犯错
不断总结
你想建立判断力就得出手
你想判断信号对不对
就得用真金白银做反馈
你想知道什么能做什么不能做
就必须先做错一堆
回头才能总结出规律
所以频繁交易的意义不是为了赚快钱
而是为了让错误更快暴露
更容易归因
你得做过几十遍被打纯的单子
回头才能发现哪类错是一再重复的
归完类才能知道哪些是选位问题
哪些是节奏问题
哪些根本不该做
但你不能靠莽
你需要把平凡变成一种可控的训练方式
真正有价值的频繁交易是建立在结构节奏
止损记录这些机制之上的
你需要每次把出手变成一次带反馈的实验
比如你可以给自己设一个简单的明确的限制
只做一小时级别的震荡区间内的高空
低多中俗的无结构中断区域直接放弃不做
因为那种区域先靠混杂
方向模糊
很容易在短线假突破里反复被洗
你做的越少
反而越清楚哪些波段是真转折
哪些只是噪音
或者你专练结果突破后的确认进场
比如双底形态
只做价格突破颈线之后回踩确认的位置不在
还没成型
右脚就硬上左侧摸底
因为左侧风险不可控
而右侧至少有结构加行为确认
哪怕错了也是在系统之内
再比如你结合50页
ma和100EMA的方向斜率来看
剧情节奏
只在均线同向
价格顺势回踩的时候出手
一旦发现两条EMA胶着或者拐头
就当做横盘过滤掉
不做
这能帮你规避趋势中断或反复震荡
导致的反复止损
你还可以用波段过滤器
把一些没什么统计优势的假信号屏蔽掉
比如你只做结构确认加波段同向假信号共振
这三个条件同时满足才进场
信号少了
但质量高了
即便是亏损也是系统内的亏损
每一单都提前写好进场逻辑
这种位置和目标位
每一单都按计划执行
事后整理归因
如果你没这么练
那你练再多也没用
但你得承认这段频繁训练期是逃不过去的
所有能做到简化等待稳定出手的交易者
早期都经历过密集出错的训练阶段
你看到那些高手节奏稳定
信号干净
出手果断
其实不是他们天赋异禀
而是他们的训练顺序比你更扎实
他们早期也试过所有错误
追高扛单
不设止损
随意下单
他们不是天生判断力强
而是每个判断都从这条路径中走出来的
你现在觉得难判断
其实是因为你根本还没联系到那些犯错样本
你的判断还停留在有没有感觉
还没建立起
有没有共性
高手和你的区别不是少错
而是他们在错之后有结构
有记录有计划的改过来
他们不只是做对的多
更是错的归的清
所以真正该想的问题不是怎么克制自己
而是怎么设计一套训练机制
让每次开单都留得下痕迹
产生复盘价值
不白死
不乱亏
李金亏损足够多之后
你会知道什么行情该做什么结构不碰
什么时候下单
什么时候该收手
你不会再靠感觉交易
而是每一类错误你都犯过一遍
系统里都纠正过一次
下一次再出现时
你知道怎么应对
这不是情绪训练
这是系统训练
不是做对几次
而是少错一次
不是为了变快
而是为了变得更可靠